[Music]
i wonder how many people are mad at just
seeing the title right now of this video
you know
enough enough people a lot of people
going yes
no no yes one of them maybe
oh i don't know what to do i hit the
dislike button in the like button can i
do both
when ezra miller shits in johnny depp's
bed then we'll all again
hi guys i got my bird's prey jacket on
john has his
jaw shirt on it's the best we could do
today
there's a shark somewhere in the dc
universe so we don't talk about a whole
lot of like
the drama on stuff you know we do it a
little bit more than usual
however these are two individuals who i
do feel very compelled to talk about
today that's the only reason i really
wanted to do it because like out of
everything i'm i'm currently hearing
right now at least in like the movie
sphere
dramatic stuff this is the one that
definitely catches my interest
the most i would like our discussions
especially on any of these subjects
because a lot of times people will
click on our videos and assume we
immediately have a side
you know and sometimes we're just
reacting to the news and dissecting it
and finding it yeah
i think we do our best to try to see as
many angles as possible that doesn't
mean we don't
land on a side we do try to at least see
as many perspectives as
as possible given a certain youtube
video runtime ezra miller
still part of the ecu as the flash amber
rehearsal
mira i probably want to talk about the
ezra miller one first here's the thing
i'm very excited for dc fandom i've been
catching up on so much dc
stuff some of the animated movies their
live action shows
the harley quinn show been catching up
on so many things you know i'm a big dc
fan
so this is in no ways like me taking
jabs at dc
i'm really i really want to talk about
like the actors
public image right now how it affects
the movies that they're apart of
yeah and i think it can affect box
office to a certain degree
and then there are some things that
personally i just feel a little bit
strong about there's all this stuff with
like ray fisher coming out right now but
there's supposed to be more to come
what he said is that there's so much
legality is involved in what he can and
cannot say so i'm kind of just waiting
for everything to come out
i feel like what he's referring to is is
basically trying to get out of that nda
so he could start talking
which is interesting because ray fisher
is tied to
ezra miller with justice league and
we're going to get more ezra miller in
the snyder cut right now with this whole
ezra miller choking fan situation we did
do a video about it but it was
right around the time when it happened
in april we were all kind of expecting
something to come out whether it be a
public apology some
phony pr press release statement
acknowledgement of any variety yeah
and there hasn't been uh any
acknowledgement of it
i genuinely find that problematic he put
up this video
uh you know was talking about how he's
gonna be a dc fandom i'm on the angle
here where i think it might be kind of
cool i don't know about the word cool
but
i think it would be perhaps depending on
how it's handled admirable
if they do acknowledge it when he's
there
and that's where he can make a statement
about it
because from everything that's come out
from people who were present at
the scene of that choking incident
in case you guys don't know ezra miller
choked a fan in uh
like iceland or something outside of a
bar and pulled her onto the ground yeah
everyone who was involved or around that
has said like no that was
real it wasn't some prank it wasn't some
trolling thing
he wasn't like just joking around he
seemed like he was actually aggressive
about it a lot of clarity could come to
mind if he did
speak on it because the thing that's
annoying to me about this
particular situation in a time of cancer
culture
there are some individuals i'm like yeah
cancel them and there's some where i'm
like
guys come on let's let's dial it back a
little bit right
yeah you know i'm not like either or
because there are
definitely so many major areas to cancel
culture that are just
ridiculous and obnoxious do something
else with your life guys come on but in
a time
of cancel culture a lot of times when
people are canceled they're like where's
the evidence
where's the evidence where's the
evidence like dude
we got a video we got a [ __ ] video
video
we're doing and a video that is at least
a small enough
glimpse that it is also dubious just in
and of what it shows
or doesn't show from the perspective of
the only people who are talking about it
are the people who were actually
some of the people who were there
present for the thing this isn't
something that i think
should be allowed to just fly under the
radar he has to acknowledge it if
anything it's like what ray fisher did
say in a tweet at the
on the day we're filming this is he did
say a over e and we were trying to
figure out like what the hell does that
mean
and i found out like accountability over
entertainment 100
agree with that especially in a
situation like this
a man choking a woman to the ground
playful or not if the woman seemed like
she was scared
hurt like we don't know the full story
we don't know the full story but right
now what we got
i think it's a terrible thing that's the
problem yeah if it was
just cut and dry they were playing
around and it was fine i feel like we
would have all
moved on and then it would have been
easy to address that yes
and we can't pick and choose who we want
to hold accountable
and who we don't want to hold
accountable yeah that's how we got this
influx that we have right now
yeah because over time we have picked in
shoes
and that's how we have like over
reactions to some things now and this is
something that
absolutely should be accountable i am at
that weird part though
where i'm like man i'm gonna be a total
hypocrite because this flash movie comes
out i'm gonna end up watching it
that's the other part too yeah
yeah and i mean you know there's also a
certain behoovement to do so i mean like
it is directly within the interests
of the stuff if you're watching that
audience here
it's a weird position we're like we kind
of have to even if we didn't have the
interest
i'm like i'm still gonna watch it yeah
yeah and it does strike me as
interesting especially in a time where
so many people
are banding behind ray fisher for this
jazz whedon stuff
and i'm kind of curious about what he
would have to say on the subject too
because i mean he's shared an ensemble
with this guy and is preaching about
accountability and bad behavior
so i i again would be curious from that
perspective too
i'm not asking for like a defense or a
damning but just yeah maybe you could
expound on that too because it seems
like a pretty big
thing to omit from this conversation
that you keep popping up
in terms of like should he be fired
yeah i would say like i don't know
that's like my honest answer is i don't
know if he should be
or shouldn't be fired it would depend on
what happens
if this were to be addressed by him yeah
exactly
now if it never gets addressed then i
might swing to the side of he's
going away with too much fire like if
the movie comes out it's a major hit and
he's never said anything about it be
like
screw this because it's like it's not
the movie i'm against it's
this uh idea that he can just get away
with something like this and we just
don't say anything about it we can
we'll just let it fly by yeah because i
think everyone has a past and everyone
makes mistakes
and people are going to make mistakes
and people are going to keep making
mistakes and a wide variety
in terms of this severity of the mistake
the thing is there's footage of this
thing
so i think something should be said that
footage and witness testimony it's kind
of just
where i'm at because i know we make a
lot of jokes but it does kind of annoy
me
yeah now more than ever i think it is
too important to
differentiate between cancel and
accountability culture because i think
that also is maybe at least in the
public side of things what halts this
from going a little bit further as
people are like
well it's either they're here or they're
canceled when really
there's a difference between
accountability and just straight up
saying no we need to
jettison this person yeah it needs to be
acknowledged in some way shape or form
otherwise it's only going to read as
we're just sweeping this under the rug
yeah exactly and there's a lot in all
these movies and studios that we just
don't hear about but there's a lot of
public things right now with dc
from behind the scenes with certain
players that whole hartley sawyer
getting fired from the flash thing
granted the tv show versus nowhere near
as big as the movies with hartley sawyer
though getting
fired this is what i mean we can't pick
and choose he makes
jokes from many many years ago that were
heinous
like wow you know i've made some pretty
messed up jokes but i wouldn't just put
it in a
text like that as an adult yeah those
were pretty
geekish shocking yeah yeah so he offends
like
groups of people with jokes ezra miller
physically in person harmed an
individual
yeah something should be said that's all
i'll say amber heard now
should she be fired okay i want to clear
up a couple of
thoughts of where i'm currently out of
my johnny depp amber heard
position in my life well around time
when we were living together i said
something about johnny depp
got a hellstorm of people coming at me
like why would you insult him he was the
one abused amber
is a liar all these things right at the
time i was 100 percent and
you know i admit it i was 100 on the
side of well
you know johnny depp's rich there's a
lot you could cover up about the guy
you know my mom was going there and then
fans were sending me like screenshots of
stuff from the court i'm like is this
court verified
like i was just really questionable
about it and i know some people who
knew johnny depp or know johnny depp
especially around that time who i
started talking to
and i'm like okay yeah but they're
johnny depp's friends
of course they're gonna have a sugar
coat version yeah
like but maybe it sounds like they were
both abusive like that's where i landed
it sounds like this was a bad
relationship it sounds like they were
very toxic with each other because this
whole trajectory after that twitter war
i had or
i went through a whole journey here
there's this channel i watched called uh
or i was like watching some of his
videos i believe
his name was incredibly average he was
releasing all kinds of things
all kinds of things that were suddenly
being publicized in this very famous
trial with johnny depp and amber heard
about him being called a wife beater by
the sun
but this guy and a couple of other
people but i think it was mainly this
guy who was releasing all this stuff for
many months
a whole bunch of audio too a lot of the
audio that is now
like oh the trial played this i'm like
dude this guy has this
this is like this guy's had it on the
internet for a while
and it just really hit me i was like
okay
here's where i stand on the johnny depp
amber heard stuff i think
there was a very toxic very abusive
relationship
on both ends however
i think what's really messed like there
were some moments apparently of some
like physical abuse incidents from
johnny depp towards amber heard
that he admitted to of like one time he
accidentally hit her on the
head according to him there's this whole
thing there right so
i don't think he's a wife beater i can't
say that
serial wife peter were they here's the
problem
that i really have with amber heard she
really painted herself in this
light like johnny depp was this
monstrosity
and amber heard was just this
completeness
victim yeah and then you hear these
audio tapes on top of the countless
witness testimonies
already being like there's just so much
where you're like oh she was messed up
there's like so much more records of her
physically harming johnny depp
i was like no they're both definitely
emotionally and verbally abusive to each
other but for sure
amber heard was physically abusive on
top of that yeah
and she was not the victim that she
painted herself out to be
and i feel like she really did take
advantage of
a lot of women who were coming forward
about the whole me too movement and
everything and she still tries to play
that card
i think it does a disservice to the me
too movement and come on if you guys
know us
we're champions of that kind of [ __ ] yes
the trial's public and the trial had to
be something famous so more people could
hear
the other side of the story and more
truths that
are backed with a lot of evidence you
know
i do think amber heard
should be fired can people see past it
here's the thing i don't know what it is
about our society i feel like for some
reason we can let that ezra miller [ __ ]
fly under the radar
yet with amber heard at this point
especially with how
public all this is double standard i
think that we
sh this has been an ongoing trial i mean
it concluded or whatever but
amber heard i think would just be such a
major
distraction i remember at that comic-con
panel when johnny depp showed up as
grindelwald and then amber heard was
there a panel on the same day for
aquaman both under the umbrella of wb
there was one person who was definitely
getting shunned a lot
and it was johnny depp amber heard
was the victim at the time and i really
feel like it would be distracting
it would be hypocritical it could be a
really negative impact
honestly i could do a whole like hour
talk obviously i've been i haven't let
john talk one people
like i could do an hour talk about this
whole thing because this is like more
nuanced and more detailed and not such a
black and white situation between giant
and amber heard
even factor in their movie careers and
how they've been affected in their
public images and yada yada yada
i just think that at this point seeing
amber hurt on screen
and anything amber herb was anything
special as mira
so i'm like i could even uh i don't
really care about her kind of thing that
you couldn't get someone else to do
yeah like she's nowhere near the main
present spotlight is
arthur curry or anyone else in that
movie for that matter yeah
nicole kidman or something like that
yeah so i'm like i i wouldn't
miss her or even the character for a
movie i really wouldn't
there's no way i could only see mira
and i i do think it it's unfair
if she's just able to thrive there's a
big difference here we've heard
so many sides of this story for a long
time piles and piles of evidence with
amber hurts it's not a black-and-white
situation of why i'm like i feel like
with ezra miller we should
hear something let's start concluding
some stuff
yeah we need more than one dangling
piece of evidence and a whole lot of
silence
whereas amber heard i'm like no i
i feel like i've made up my mind on this
one yeah yeah
yeah i do sway on the side of i think
she ought to be let go
especially at this point it'd just be
like it would be a major distraction
i feel that toward the both of them
honestly at this moment because it is
the sort of thing where the further you
dig into this case the uglier it all
gets and it's clear that these two
people
perhaps need a infinite space from each
other but b
some help at the moment i don't know and
yeah
especially for a character's profile in
a movie as profile
as aquaman and for as vocal as the fans
are
i do feel like they probably will be in
a position where
replacing her is probably what they want
to do because yeah you don't want
this being the thing everyone brings up
and two people
are such that i hesitate with this
because yeah i mean amber hurt is a
great example of somebody who
has not necessarily portrayed herself
super truthfully
or necessarily super accurately and uh i
think you're correct
in assuming that ezra miller's
transgression
is one that i just assume yeah the
public is likely
more so to forget about whereas i can
imagine that same public being very
vocal about aquaman 2 being just over
the corner and amber heard still being a
part of it um
and that's something that you know wb
wants to avoid i'm sure
and as much as controversy as they can
get away from from these movies i think
the better
but also yeah i mean if you're just
talking to me as a human being and i'm
i'm listening to these details and you
probably have more
obviously details of my case than i know
i've
heard everything that think you can
possibly hear
it's rare in a toxic relationship that
both sides are not abusive to one
another it's just an abusive
relationship
both these people need a timeout the
thing is i i have a hard time believing
that johnny depp was this this monster
to this poor girl yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the part of the story where i'm
like no
there's a lot of false narrative here i
could see that and
being a talks relationship that's your
private business but man the fact that
it became public
i feel like johnny depp got duped on a
lot here and got wronged on a lot and
not enough people are
also hearing at least his side of the
story so everyone can
draw a certain conclusion for their own
basically
to me they're they're on a roughly a
similar level it's just that johnny
depp's case has improved to me over time
while amber herds is significantly
weakened
and now and because the thing is too
like i think amber hurd is a good
actress i've seen her in things i've
really liked obviously johnny depp is
part of some of my favorite favorite
movies but i do feel i was just watching
uh
murder on the orient express a couple
weeks ago and this was kind of the first
thing i thought about so i feel like
less so to johnny depp but they both are
carrying this around right now
and it's gonna be a thing that you think
about whenever you see each of them
i'm not necessarily saying recast
grindelwald 2 but i feel like we at very
least need
a break for these people to go sort
themselves out there's just so much
mounting
against johnny depp showing like what
did he lie about exactly
and then with amber heard you're like oh
she lied about so much
and she yeah that whole thing with her
having a bruised eye
there's so much evidence at least that's
what was reported there
what was the evidence that was brought
that that was painted on
oh man that just that really boggles my
that
bothers me that everyone's just kind of
running with that story and i was one of
them
yeah that's the thing yeah and that's
probably why i feel so passionate about
it now yeah
one it is interesting too to me because
it's not that the actor needs to match
the character in terms of their moral
compass or whatever but you do have mira
who is
a hero figure in the awkward story
public image can be so distracting
that's why
no that's what i'm saying is you don't
need them to match however i think in
this
case scenario amber heard has had
information revealed about her either
through herself or other people that has
proven that she's
not in any way as as upstanding as that
character and so there is again you
don't need your actors to morally align
but at the same time
it does seem a little bit
counterintuitive to be like wow you're
responsible for some pretty terrible
behavior over the past several years and
also you're this hero here so it almost
seems like a
spiritually good choice to find a
different presence to occupy that role
to me it's weird because i'm sure that
there is some level of double standard
going in here where people are more apt
to attack and punish amber heard harder
than perhaps
and ezra miller if that amounts to more
than it is right now
but at the same time what's been
revealed is very very ugly
i mean if you don't compare amber heard
to ezra miller and you just isolate the
situation i feel like
everything that's bad about johnny depp
we've already known for such a long time
like
yeah like it's alcoholism and drug
addiction stuff these patterns that he
has
that he's admitted to you know yeah and
like like partying like the rock star
that he is sometimes like he can have
like a temper problem but his whole
argument was wife beater and he's like
that's not what i
was everything was pinpointing back to
that so he admitted to like a whole list
of other things i did some bad [ __ ] but
i wasn't that
yeah that's the whole point like no no i
did that i was that but
not that and i mean that paints a more
uh genuine at least
persona yeah you know that's what i mean
than it does somebody who's like i was
attacked
except i did a lot of stuff and i
maybe blew some of this out of
proportion and and and
that's a mess um but yeah holy mess all
right guys
well who should stick around and who
should be
fired who should be fired next next week
we'll see
a whole bunch of evidence come out about
giant up and i'll be like ah [ __ ] gotta
make another video
you know well hey maybe we can just
flip-flop every week more evidence
less evidence yeah more ever change in
opinion an opinion is a finite piece of
material
manifested in the universe yeah that's
the backbone of american politics
don't ever update your information once
you've chosen it
what would you do that for how are
people gonna know what you stand for if
you
update all right guys leave your
thoughts down below
either way dc fandom we've got more dc
stuff
fun time